my business has gotten hammered with the
corona of our shutdown has an advanced
well david has and you know the thing i
want to tell people is just what you're
hearing in the headline certainly is
rough for those that this has affected
and at the same time I've been talking
with dozens of small business owners
over the last couple weeks and there's
really three categories of business
right now there's there's businesses who
are actually trying to figure out how to
scale up to this opportunity you know my
dad's got a water business in West Texas
and they had record sales last week if
you're in a cleaning sir well they they
have a drinking water that's a tap at
the sink and people don't want to go to
the store and buy bottled water right
now so for whatever reason they're going
hey let's get this car installed in our
house he's a Kinetico dealer that's a
cola can water conditioning yeah okay
cleaning services IT services anything
that has to do with working from home
anything that has to do with I went to
my favorite local burger place today and
they said hey we're not doing the dining
room thing but our kitchen is slammed
and we got calls and we're running them
out to the car and we're actually trying
to find some some cooks right now some
help because we got to fulfill the
demand and so there's been a huge
disruption but there are businesses who
are actually trying to booming their
booming and exploding and their higher I
don't want to shut down and as we also
show down the restaurants are down
I'm gonna tell you that just in my my
non-formal survey and talking to my
friends and people in our entre
leadership community there's this this
group in the middle between booming and
shutting down that they're just adapting
and responding they're shifting how
they're doing business you know I talked
to a friend last night whose company
they teach music lessons to students
they have music instructors and kids
come into their studio and they're just
doing it virtually now they're figuring
it out and what I love about business
owners and entrepreneurs is they are
they are problem solvers by nature and
they're not just going to take two weeks
off they're not just going to lay back
and say well let's just see when this
this passes and then we'll get back to
work
they're figuring out how to continue
work continue communicating with the
team as best they can in light of these
circumstances and again when it comes to
getting a job what that spells is
opportunity that's absolutely right your
righteous equals opportunity here yeah
you're looking at your priorities right
now and if
you've been laid off or you feel you're
gonna get laid off you need to be
identifying companies that Daniels
talking about that are ramping up right
now because of the increased demand and
you're gonna see a lot of opportunities
for hourly jobs that can supplement the
income take care of the four walls that
you teach during this time of
uncertainty and then as the economy
comes back you know I had a guy calling
my show today he's in the automobile
industry he said can i I'm gonna be laid
off tomorrow on Friday and he said but
I'm pretty assured my leadership told me
it's probably two to three months max
I'm coming back it was a three months
what they said now you know every
situation is different but he's going
what do I do in the firt in those next
two to three months I said whatever it
takes if it's to three jobs you know
it's the same type of ghazal intensity
when you're trying to get out of debt
and what we do right now is we go let's
take care of the four walls but there is
opportunity heard a story today in
Nashville guys and gals that are running
food trucks that really rely on foot
traffic in Nashville okay if this is a
heavy tourism city and they have now
gotten themselves into the food delivery
business where you know organizations
that are staying open or those that are
shut-in if you will need food and they
have adapted and so the entrepreneurial
spirit is very much alive and you know I
remember talking a long time ago to
Bobbie Grunwald is a mutual friend of
all three of ours a great innovator he
said you know when you have a lack of
resources and those resources right now
could be customers actually buying your
product and so things have been shrunk
that's where great innovation happens
because you don't have any choice but to
innovate and so I think as leaders if we
cannot be afraid right now and we can be
clear on here's where we stand now
here's what we do know here's what we
don't know listen I'm eunuch a torch to
our team let's communicate to our tribe
and let's roll our sleeves up and figure
out away good things will happen
yeah and Dave kiddin what ken is saying
essentially is when you combine
capitalism and entrepreneurs in America
and you go the economy is getting
suppressed what happens is like a beach
ball that you hold underwater that beach
ball is coming back up yeah you hold
underwater for a week two weeks three
weeks now if this administration ties it
and chains and ties it to a boat anchor
we got a different problem right but
we're
back to work and what entrepreneurs are
doing right now is they're getting ready
they're adapting their catch they got a
little free time so they're catching up
on some stuff that was more
administrative getting their
documentation updated they're getting
ready to come back and surge back once
all this crap kind of moves on and we
can get back to business yeah yeah it's
what you said earlier
Daniel was really important what
business what small business does by its
very nature the DNA of small business
people is they're problem solvers that's
right and some of them have astronomical
intimidating problems in front of them
right now and they're some of them are
their hearts are breaking because
they're having to layoff people that
they love they can't pay the bill they
can't because they don't have the
revenue right now they and and it just
rips that rips the heart out your chest
when you're an employer and you can't
keep your folk because someone just just
said okay we're shutting the whole thing
down I mean you're shutting the whole
thing down we're shutting the whole
thing down what about these families
that depend on us to eat what about
their kids you know that that's where we
buy their food that's where they buy
their electricity what about that
doesn't matter we're shutting the whole
thing down
and so yeah and so a lot of
entrepreneurs are finding themselves
small business people are finding
themselves in this so here's some
interesting numbers to think through for
a second for those of you out there
fifty-four percent of the gross domestic
product is produced with goods and
services by small businesses and have
less than 500 team members and they are
in jeopardy right now fifty-four percent
of our entire economy is on the bubble
right this second because of because you
just shut them down and I understand why
you show them that I understand about
that understand her there's a thing
called the coronavirus I know this
happened okay but the unemployment
numbers and the job loss has skyrocketed
now here's the deal the GDP of the
United States the gross domestic product
the United States is right around 20
trillion dollars Washington just passed
a bill
to stimulate the economy for two
trillion dollars by following this well
percentage of 20 is to 10 percent so
this is like your grown daughter calling
you she's 30 years old near 65 and she
says oh no oh no I lost my job and you
say okay I'm gonna pay your bills for
one month so what's she gonna do after
that yeah you're squirting a forest fire
with a squirt gun yep right I mean
that's not gonna be the solution that
one what I said so it's like peeing on a
forest fire that doesn't smell this gets
about is useful and when you effect a
mathematical problem about 10% you
didn't affect the mathematical process
right that's right and so people not
working is going to cause great pain in
America so we're with you small
businesspeople we're we're on your team
or one of you when we're gonna talk
about at this hour on the Dave Ramsey
show